when you see companies going public like
that and you see either retail investors
i think it's retail investors maybe who
are embracing these what is your
thinking of
how they need to change their thinking
uh which beth kept saying like hey you
gotta you gotta maybe develop a
different skill set what do you think
that skill set is and should they even
be touching those
um i wouldn't say you shouldn't be
touching them i think it you know for me
what i do is you know i've been
in the public markets in equities since
2007 so that's what i know that's what i
uh that's the skill set to bring to the
table um
and there were some strong winners for a
time being in this back market still are
some some good names so to ignore that
completely
um
i think could fall on the trap that i
see a lot of people do in finances
they'll look at valuations and they'll
say this is insane it makes no sense i'm
staying away
and they miss out on one of the most
epic bull markets um
uh i mean arguably in history um yeah
and so spax being a part of that um
you know i think the the main thing i
would say is you have to investing in
something with very little price data to
analyze and that is an untested um that
is an untested uh
product in the public markets is you
have to have some kind of risk
management plan you have to have some
kind of exit strategy um when doing
something like that i mean that's how we
approach the spac market
is um you know we found some stories
that we liked uh we played some momentum
uh some price setups that we liked and
we had an exit strategy and when it got
triggered we stepped away
oh interesting so give me an example
either one of you of like an interesting
stack story that you embraced and either
stuck with or just decided wow this is
getting overvalued and decided to just
take that win
i can give you the one that we liked
that we are the io fund is still
invested in it's called stem
it's batteries but it's also software
that um optimizes how the battery is
used because the statistics are about 40
of solar energy or any whatever it might
be uh renewable energy is wasted because
of the lack of optimization when should
you be on a generator when should you be
relying on the battery
um so it's called athena software and
the reason why we like stem is that they
had already met their full-year revenue
guidance and they had no debt
so that combination puts them in a
little bit of a different category than
one that might turn around and raise
really quickly uh dilute shareholders
and or is projecting some
number that they cannot meet
um and then we are really interesting
just as a follow-up there
uh that stock traded i guess like all
stacks at ten dollars while they were
looking for it then popped up as high as
it looks like uh
well 50 bucks a share and then now it's
trading at 23. so you doubled your money
if you bought into that story early but
it's one you want to stick with and if i
read into it
they have a product that they have
customers for and they're paying for it
so you've checked a couple of boxes
there a paying customer and a real
product are two of them am i correct
yeah that's always helpful
yeah i mean i say that
and it sounds so stupid when i say it
but then you look at nicola as the
opposite and i don't know if you were
involved in that train wreck uh no no
okay great because i had that dip on the
pod
and when he explained the product to me
there were so many red flags going off
for me as a private market investor
because he's like well we're going after
these like hydrogen stuff and i can do
it 10 times cheaper i said how do you do
it 10 times cheaper
and he couldn't answer the question and
then he said well i'm also going to do
electric and do a badger thing and i
just thought to myself wow
i watched elon and other people suffer
just pursuing one electrical new
energy model he's going to pers this
person's going to pursue two
simultaneously and it's worth 40 billion
now and they haven't they don't have a
car on the road so this is a really
important lesson for people no customers
no product no revenue is a really
different class of business is it not
yes i would even extend that to say
lucid motors which i think one day could
be a quality company but today as a
stock investor there's not much i can do
with that company because they haven't
put cars on the road
and it seems hard to get the first car
on the road
right yeah right
histories
i mean it's a it's a it's a tough
business model just just auto companies
i mean
historically have been some of the worst
uh i mean aside from tesla obviously but
some of the worst industries to invest
in
so once you get past the high growth
tech store you then have to deal with
the auto industry nightmare i don't know
you know the way it put it from just a
financial standpoint
literally the worst
companies we look at as private market
investors that we get the most concerned
about
anybody going into healthcare higher
education
right cars you're just like and the
music industry because the it's a
combination of incumbents and regulation
and just
how in some cases dog it is and cars
fall into that um
this is a company that has a market cap
of 32 billion dollars
today
at
20 bucks a share
and it was as high as 60 to 4 so if i'm
correct doing my math here i'm no genius
it was a close to 100 billion company
what do you attribute that kind of
insanity to
at this moment in time actually knox is
a great person to ask because his trait
i mean his talent is that he tracks
sentiment in the markets
so he's actually the perfect person for
that so i think i think um
one of the most interesting
hurdles we've had to address
and i'll tie this into your question was
how this market is not like 1999.
i think 1999 i mean
is still
earmarked in a lot of people's minds
and so people will look at these
valuations and look at the growth and
they'll say oh this is a bubble and so
what followed that bubble was
just a terrifying awful multi-year bear
market you know and so you live through
that and i'm not sure how old you are
but i lived through that i wasn't
investing during that yeah i started i
got licensed in 2007 so i got to start
out
basically in you know a multi-year bear
market that was absolutely horrifying
you know and and i mean that was what 12
years ago and so so many investors today
think that a bear market was what
happened last year
you know just right now no no big deal
you know and they they're they're very
big deals they're awful deals to go
through
um so my point being is that you had
this bubble it didn't make sense it was
irrational it was momentum driven it was
human psychology followed by a bear
market and think of all the bubbles that
we've seen in the last few years i mean
i i can round off we just saw a bubble
in lumber for example you know that
popped and so bubbles don't mean bear
markets
it definitely means there's an excess of
liquidity
um and it definitely means that there's
an exuberance in the market but um what
leads to bear markets and recessions
typically is central bank policy which
is incredibly loose right now they're
stuck in they have backed themselves
into a corner and they just told us a
few weeks ago that they're they're going
to let the party go on a little bit a
little bit longer
every startup founder and marketer needs
high quality leads well with 30 million
companies on linkedin they can help you
take your startups growth to the next
level we've used linkedin marketing
before here at this week in startups and
launch our investment firms it's really
an amazing platform as you know because
you've been using it for over a decade
linkedin offers seamless tools for lead
generation and brand building first you
might want people to just become aware
of your brand maybe you want them to
read a blog post or follow your company
on linkedin that's great for building
your brand but you may at some point
want that legion you may want to get
their email and set up a demo of your
software product or your marketplace you
understand the difference between these
things you're sophisticated and you know
you can target and reach people down to
their job titles the company name and
location engaging customers by account
allowing you to build relationships with
your most important acquisition targets
where they live and where they're ready
to do business and that's linkedin so
linkedin's advertising capabilities will
allow you to acquire those new customers
and to grow existing accounts so that
your business is set up to maximize its
potential here is an amazing offer from
our friends at linkedin they're offering
a hundred dollars in advertising credits
so that you can get started today learn
how to connect with customers on
linkedin's dime visit linkedin.com this
week in startups and you gotta spell
this all out with no spaces and no
dashes linkedin.com slash this week in
startups to claim your credit terms and
conditions do apply because they're
giving you a hyundai